now that this is wrapped up could it be
could the young adult movie genre be
done I never hear about him anymore it's
all comic book movies star wars and bad
horror not a lot of young adult maybe
it's over
[Music]
Maze Runner death cure so Maze Runner
death cure is the third installment in
The Maze Runner franchise first Maze
Runner remarkably enjoyable second one
scorch trials remarkably not now we've
hit death Keira basically this is a
rescue mission they're out there in
their Mad Max ish kind of way they need
to get into this city this is actually a
pretty good stronghold like it was
plucked out of the future and plucked
into this [ __ ] guy still says [ __ ]
all it's a [ __ ] so I gotta go into
this fortress and get there friend
pretty much the gist granted one thing
leads to another in this movie it being
the concluding chapter of a trilogy but
I like this movie Dylan O'Brien the
little Brian is a pretty charismatic
dude Dylan O'Brien's one of those actors
even when Dylan O'Brien is in a piece of
[ __ ] Dylan O'Brien is still good in that
piece of [ __ ] and when the climax of
this movie was going down it felt like
gloves Rob keep your eye on the
background [ __ ] is always happening
makes the world feel lived in it makes
the threat feel real that the worst
wound it's like it's all that war and
then when something's happening here you
look in the background you're like I'm
pretty sure nothing's going on back
there this movie had a big hurdle to get
over with me and that is the fact that I
don't really remember Scorch Trials at
all this is that moment you realize my
rating system isn't really a rating
system it just illustrates my state of
mind when I say I'm not gonna remember a
movie in t-minus one day I mean I'm not
going to remember it and I don't grant
it if I were a responsible human being I
would have taken a couple hours out of
my day to catch up on Scorch Trials
there's no [ __ ] realm of reality
where I'm gonna revisit a shitty movie
for the sake of that I'm not gonna do it
and really I guess this is me saying
this movie could have benefited from
some text something to catch us up on
the whole thing
we Blade Runner 2049 had text like okay
this is what happens is what you miss
even Spiderman 3 had a little montage at
the beginning like earlier is
everything's leading up to this this
could have used something but he just
starts you off on Mad Max steals a train
maybe I'm the only one who will feel
this loss coming into the movie I'm
saying the movie was delayed it's been a
while I don't know that there's a lot of
people who are like I need to watch
Scorch Trials twice cuz it's [ __ ]
awesome I just personally felt that
could have used something to refresh our
memory but the main character and his
friend like their friendship in this
movie made it for me one thing in
particular was done I felt very well it
saved the movie for me it's the thing I
can look at and be like no there's the
light among all the cliches in this
movie right down to the point where they
get to the helipad like nothing's here
and I'm like wait for it just just wait
for it oh there they come they're a
little late I saw that in aliens there's
so many things in this movie you've seen
in so many other movies it kind of gets
old and tired at a pond
but that friendship and that arc showed
me that there could have been a lot more
going on here and I don't care about any
of the romances either yes I guess you
had a romance with one other guy I don't
care I remember he had a romance with
the other girl but still didn't care all
these things that bring us into the
characters worlds and make us root for
them so you want to see the world get
cured I didn't care about any of it I
really didn't care if the world got
cured and the pacing in this movie was
off too it's two and a half hours long
it should have been two hours long
you're gonna have a two and a half hour
long movie have compelling characters as
I stated they really didn't I firmly
believe there's nothing this movie did
in two and a half hours that it couldn't
have done in two hours this movie does
have some enjoyment in it as an
infiltration movie it is at his baseline
entertaining or I should say its
baseline entertaining at its max its
baseline entertaining you know the man
it's not breaking new ground here it's
full of cliches so it doesn't make it
terrible it just makes it cliche how
much cliche pisses you off that's as
welders you're metric and the movie felt
a bit unfulfilled at the end because of
the fact I guess it's the concluding
chapter of a trilogy in this movie and
it alls like alright I guess we're
waiting for the next one Daniel artists
the concluding chapter of the trilogy so
I guess there's not gonna be another one
guys in the end death care I can say
this better than the second one dylan
o'brien carries the movie the friendship
between him and who's one friend that's
the friendship that makes it for me
didn't really care about anyone else the
first act of the movie this set up i
thought was just choppy as hell but all
in all i think i have found the recipe
to enjoy this movie and that is blood
alcohol content because Maze Runner
death care has enjoyment but would
probably be a better time if I were
drunk yeah now it's a party guys so Maze
Runner death cure have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you
[Music]